Welcome back
to another Wine Down this week.
Today we're joined by writer,
co-producer, actor,
the multi-talented hyphenate,
Natasha Rothwell,
who you all know
and love as Kelli.
Yes! Kelli has always been
a ride or die,
and in this episode, Ready-Like,
we see her start to feel
-some jealousy towards Tiffany
-PRENTICE PENNY: Mmm.
and her new pregnant friends.
Is there trouble in paradise?
I mean, when your friend
makes a life choice
that doesn't include you,
it can make you feel, uh...
a type of way.
One of those interesting things
that we talked about
in the writer's room
was just exploring this dynamic
between friends.
-When a baby comes along,
-PRENTICE: Yeah.
-when there's a life change,
-NATASHA ROTHWELL: Yeah.
-things change, inevitably.
-Yes.
And one of the things we've seen
for Kelli and Tiffany's
relationship is that
they've always been
closer friends
than Issa's been
to either one of them
and Molly has been
to either one of them.
-NATASHA: Yes.
-So, talk about just...
where Kelli and Tiffany's
relationship stands
after this episode.
Kelli's incredibly hurt
that Tiffany has moved on
without her
and that her role
in Tiffany's life
is up for grabs.
And I feel like, also too,
that what I found interesting
in this particular episode
and my personal life
because I've lost friends
to relationships before
and to their
life choices before,
it's just a necessary episode
to explain what actually happens
at this point in our lives
when we're this age, you know?
-NATASHA: When we're in our 30s,
-ISSA AND PRENTICE: Yeah.
and making choices
that really define
what your friendships
will look like.
-Tiffany's baby shower
was extra as fuck by design.
-NATASHA: Yes, yes.
One of the most fun things to do
was have Amanda,
who was also just gleeful,
-to be able to do a photoshoot
-Just gleeful.
-PRENTICE: To be an icon.
ISSA AND NATASHA: To be an icon!
To be an icon. To be Beyoncé.
-To be Serena. To be Cardi B.
-NATASHA: Yes.
It looked incredible.
-You know Amanda's gonna keep
those baby shower pictures,
-Oh!
-and I'm like, but you're not--
-PRENTICE: And use them later?
You're not preg--
So what are you gonna--
-So people are gonna come and--
-Sit on 'em.
You just sit on 'em!
-You just sit on 'em.
-ISSA: "Oh, you're pregnant?"
(LAUGHING)
Well, the other big thing
that we introduced
-in this episode...
-PRENTICE: Yeah!
-...is Lawrence's storyline.
-Guess who's back?
ISSA AND NATASHA:
Guess who's back?
So we decided to do
a "previously on" montage,
-which I know was
a fun discussion in the room
-Yeah.
of just like being able
to catch the audience on
where he's been
and what he's been up to?
It was fun
to talk about sort of...
'Cause typically, like,
before we started the season,
we'd sort of talk about
all of our characters,
sort of what are they doing?
What are their story lines?
But this year, we're obviously,
were talking more about Daniel
and sort of the world
that he occupied,
so for us with Lawrence,
it was challenging
but refreshing
to sort of talk about
what has Lawrence
really been up to.
And the slate was kind of
really open, you know?
Obviously, we're tied to sort of
where the season ended,
but it was fun to talk about
sort of what he's doing
and where he is and sort of
where do we want him to go
from here on?
-So... (CHUCKLES)
-Mmm-hmm?
-This montage of seeing
what Lawrence has been up to
-Mm-hmm?
since we last left him,
is that realistic?
Like, is that what guys
go through post-breakup? Post--
-ISSA: hurt.
-Yeah! I mean,
I think like right now,
yeah, I think he's definitely,
not exorcising some demons
to some degree,
but he's like, look,
I'm single, I'm not, you know,
post-Aparna, like I'm just...
I'm just chillin',
I'm just out here.
I think the difference
between last year and this year
is last year,
he felt the hurt of Issa.
It almost felt like
he was trying to really,
really, really get it out, like
I'ma fuck the hurt outta me.
-Right, medicinal fucking.
-Right, I'm medicinal fucking,
and this year,
he's like, he's kinda like,
I'm just out here,
I'm just, I don't have
any of that energy to me,
but I'm single,
I'm a good-looking dude,
I'm making some money now,
I'm not on the couch.
It feels like
a serial monogamist trying on
what just being out there
is like, 'cause like you said,
the first time around,
it was just, like, out of hurt,
and this time,
it's just like, well,
I've been in a relationship
for so long,
I don't know what it's like
to just be out there.
-And not have to do that.
-So, it's... yeah.
-But it's tough with dudes.
When dudes date,
I don't know if it's like...
when you're wired,
if dudes are wired that way
or not but there is always
that thing where you're like,
"Oh, she's cute! I wanna see
if I can try and fuck...
-You know what I mean? Like...
-(LAUGHING)
When you're single
and doing that,
-you know what I mean?
I'm not saying it's great...
-(GIGGLING)
I'm just saying, yo,
we at the club, that's...
You know? 'Cause dudes
don't just go out with dudes
and just... I mean,
they go out to kick it, but...
-They don't get to hang out?
-(GIGGLES)
-But women go to a club--
-Just hanging
with my boyfriends!
and they're like,
we just dancing with my girls.
If dudes go out
like single dudes,
it's like there's a mission!
-It's like, you single,
-There's a mission.
you tryin' to go out and like,
be out there!
Just not trying to have fun,
enjoy each other's company?
Just enjoy the night?
If somebody don't go home,
-and leave the group?
-(LAUGHING)
It's a bust. In my single days,
I've seen dudes where I was like
he could be in a ditch
right now, I have no idea,
but he winnin' 'cause
he's not with the rest of us
at Jerry's Deli eating pastrami.
(LAUGHING)
-He out there--
-He out there, winnin' or dead!
He's either dead or fucking,
but he winnin' on some side.
(LAUGHING)
As a fan of the show,
like I cannot wait
for the next episode
to see, like, where...
-You know.
-I mean, I know,
-but they don't know what I know
but I'm a fan of...
-(LAUGHING)
-I... Let me have this.
-Okay.
(LAUGHING)
As always, thank you
for wining down with us,
-and see you next time! Cheers!
-Cheers!
-Cheers.
-Cheers, cheers, cheers.